and carbon-based fuel is the most
efficient source of energy
although second hold on a second ring
ring Angela Merkel oh it's for you she
says that's bullsh alright thanks for
glad to be with you last installment did
was with Jordan Peterson a lot of
feedback people really enjoyed it wanted
to get some more prominent conservatives
on the show just to talk about you know
most pressing issues - the most
requested person was our necks yes and
the topic we'll be discussing today here
in devil's advocate is basically the
merits and the drawbacks of socialism
he's the host of the Benjamin Shapiro
program on The Daily Caller thanks for
your time Benjamin absolutely skylark
heard uh-oh thank you free [ __ ] you
being here so obviously we'll be talking
about socialism if someone is very
popular at your shows where I do a lot
of you know QAS and you're very popular
in conservative circles and far-right
circles and all tried circles I've heard
a lot of this you know socialism is evil
socialism is theft I wanna know why you
believe that to the case I've heard you
talk about it because obviously in
principle I mean will be agree that in
principle it's good you know Old
Testament talks a lot about not
oppressing the poor giving to the poor
often the rich are portrayed as villains
because of their greed so I was a
descendant of the Jewish people and
faith who we're not agree that helping
the poorest among us is is a moral
immoral mission sure I mean that's
called charity but what is not moral is
stealing money for me to give to
somebody else on the part of a
government the points a gun at me that's
that's not an actual thing and the Bible
doesn't talk about that in any way did
the Bible and if we want to talk about
the biblical dictates with regard to
charity yeah
there's Emily Newton Hebrew I mean
there's master there's master Shanee
there's true there's pan like that like
there there's a bunch of different
aspects of Jewish law that talked about
charity but they are all relegated to
the the realm of private charity meaning
that it's more about my obligation to
give charity and less about your
rights to my money so we're supposed to
recognize that wealth belongs to God but
my wealth does not belong to you in the
in the biblical view sure well I was
using ignore as a moral sort of using as
a moral deem I don't really want to get
off on sort of the metaphysical and God
and that kind I don't want to get into
God's definition of what's necessarily
moral but the idea that as a society its
moral to help the poorest among us
especially when we look at systemic
right oppression of the poor as we see
we're not just talking about a level
playing field right we're talking about
a playing field where the middle classes
is shrunken dramatically we're talking
about you know wages have not kept up
with inflation the rich keep getting
richer that gap keeps widening so
there's a system in place which to me
yeah none that's true no that's no
that's actually true is the problem so
actually the middle class in the United
States the upper middle class was about
12% of the population of the United
States in 1979 and by 2014 that was 30
percent of the American population so
the disappearance of the middle class
folks talk about is really the middle
class becoming upper-middle class and
the standard of living for everyone in
the United States has risen dramatically
since 1979 one of the favorite
statistics folks like to cite here is
they say that there's been wage
stagnation in hourly wages since 1979
adjusted for inflation well that's true
it also doesn't not entirely obviously
because it was you know minimum wage
laws which we'll get to in a bit well
the fact is yeah we do that in a second
but the fact is that the wage stagnation
that has taken place does not take into
account additional benefits which is 30
to 40 percent on top of the salary it
doesn't take into account the different
way that we count households then we
used to it also doesn't take into
account the fact that you can get more
stuff for the same inflation adjusted
dollar than you could in 1979 you have a
nicer fridge now than he did in 1979 and
it costs you basically half of what it
would have in 1979 an inflation adjusted
dollars so if you're getting twice as
much stuff for the same buck now that
means that you're basically twice as
rich as you would have been in 1979 and
for anyone who disagrees I would
recommend you go back to 1979 and live
in 1979 and see whether your standard of
living is the same whether you enjoy it
well now we're getting back into the
meta economist Benjamin Shapiro if we'll
have a time-traveling machine let's try
and keep it in you know reality like you
say fax fax don't care about your
time-traveling machine
what about homes
what about homes you know what about
retirement middle-class family today is
much more difficulty affording a home
you know if you go back to the 50s you
could live in a single income household
and have the vehicle have a home retire
at a reasonable age that's not the case
now who really cares if you have you
know Frigidaire in your kitchen well I
mean I've got a couple of things about
this one homes in the United States have
radically increased in size over time so
homes back in the 1950s you can see this
when you go check them out
much smaller than the homes that are
being built now to the increase in home
prices is really because of this massive
urbanization that's happened where
people are rushing into massive cities
and these cities are heavily zoned so
that's created an incredible shortage of
housing in major liberal cities you're
not seeing the same sort of housing
shortages in places that don't have
those same sort of zoning regulations
places like Dallas places in the middle
of the country you're mostly seeing it
in Seattle LA San Francisco New York
places where it's difficult to build new
buildings and where the government has
mandated that you also build affordable
housing tax you heavily created new
regulations that's what's creating a
serious pressure in that sphere right
right so it's a it's the government's
fault I just wanna make sure I have this
this right so it's the government's
fault that people cannot afford homes
it's the government's fault or that peep
that the the wage gap is actually
increasing that the middle class is
shrinking I know you say it's not but we
look at the 1% who are wealthier than
ever before and the rest of the
population right that time oh no the
wealth gap the the fact that there is a
greater disparity between the top tax
bracket the bottom tax bracket is true
but the bottom tax bracket is a lot
richer than it used to be and again one
of the things that is a huge mistake
folks make when it comes to analyzing
economic issues is the suggestion that
if you are in the top 1% you are always
in the top 1% you started there you
finish there you live there you died
there there are people I've been in the
top 1% I've been not in the top 1%
people tend to get wealthier as they get
older and so the upper tax brackets are
disproportionately older than the lower
tax brackets again that movement is
suggestive of the facts that folks are
earning more and less over the course of
their lifetime it's not just like
there's this ingrown cased of people who
are born rich and stay rich inherited
wealth accounts for very little of the
the top tax brackets yeah well you know
I I've heard this talked about a lot
sort of class mobility so I think it's
often referred to what I've noticed it
seem you talk about going back to 1979
you talk about how these people will be
wealthier down the line as they get
older again we're kind of in the realm
of meta economics right things that you
feel will happen down the line but
that's not what's happening with these
people right now
when you're talking about these people
today in 2018 who can't afford to go to
college who can't afford to purchase a
home who can't afford health insurance
right Oh Benjamin Shapiro of The Daily
collars if his ideal world works out
down the line these people will be great
they'll be the next coax or whatever but
today that's not the case
well my deal worked out if my ideal
world worked out what you'd have is
lower prices and better products in
virtually every area of American life
from health care to colleges the fact is
the government subsidies are one of the
areas that's creating upward pressure
and prices when you give a bunch of
people subsidies to go to college what
you are doing is generating additional
supply or additional demand without
additional supply that creates upward
pricing pressure I mean this is a simple
supply demand curve and the fact that
folks on the Left don't seem to
understand this they think that if you
just dumped a bunch of money into free
college education that this is going to
somehow alleviate all of the all of the
economic woes of a society that is
already absorbing the cost of a bunch of
college graduates who can't get jobs
because they majored in silly things
it's it's a little bit bewildering and
in fact it's really interesting a lot of
the socialist countries that socialists
like to talk about the the quad you know
the quote-unquote socialist countries of
Scandinavia they have a lot more heavily
regimented idea of what colleges should
be for I mean if you look at Sweden if
you look at Switzerland there's a lot
more tracking people who are going to
colleges or vocational schools based on
the vocation they wish to pursue liberal
arts majors in in Scandinavia
significantly less of the college
population than in the United States
because they feel like if they're gonna
get the government to sponsor college
degrees at least you should come out
with some marketable skills okay so it's
interesting you point to a lot of these
candidate event countries and we talked
about that on my program quite a bit
Denmark Sweden Norway so it sounds like
you'd be okay with sort of moving toward
the more socialist model they use in
those countries that are really quite
successful we've heard obviously senator
Sanders and people like Cortez talking
about says a lot of people said there
are no successful socialist country I
would point to well I mean and and this
has become the favorite the kind of
favorite tool of quote-unquote
socialists today's to pick countries
that have built their entire wealth
based on capitalism and then have placed
on top of that capitalism some
redistribution of systems then call this
country socialist that's not a socialist
country a socialist country is a country
that uses abolition of profit as a tool
and nationalization of property as a
chief tool and public ownership of the
means of production as the chief tool of
wealth production and distribution
that's not actually what happens in
Denmark or Norway or Switzerland or
Sweden or any of these countries which
is why the prime minister of Denmark
suggested back in 2015 when Bernie
Sanders kept jabbering about Denmark
being a socialist country went to
Harvard Kennedy School government he
said we're not a socialist country or a
capitalist country all of these
supposedly socialist countries ranked
around or higher than the United States
and the Heritage Foundation free
economic Freedom Index than the United
States does which would suggest that
these are these are not actually
countries that are focused sincerely on
regulation of business above all and
redistribution of property through the
means of brigham a jump in there I think
it's important that we you know the
economic freedom index like we're
talking about there Canada was higher
than the United States for a little
longer even though they have a universal
health care plan so it sounds to me like
you're okay with sort of the model that
we see the Nordic model so then would we
be okay with a universal healthcare
program or a single-payer because if you
look at these countries that you just
said right are not socialist but then if
we're trying to mind it here in the
United States people say oh that's
socialized health care Universal
socialist right so the program can be
socialist but the question of communes
hire a country socialist because it has
a socialist program in medicine that's
that's a little bit silly I mean it's
like suggesting that you who have a job
and you bring home money to your family
and then you redistribute the money
among members of your family you have a
joint bank account with your wife this
means you're a socialist no you're a
capitalist who is who uses socialist
methods of redistribution in your own
home it's the same thing with Norway or
Denmark
then we have to look at the efficacy of
those programs we also have to look at
the rights of the people that are being
violated by those programs do you have a
right to your own use of Labour's you
have a right to the the product of your
labor do you have a right to the
alienation of your labor and then we
also have to look at whether any of
those even if you believe that it didn't
violate rights you'd have to look at
whether those programs were adaptable to
the United States which typically they
have not been because the reality is
that in places like Sweden or Norway or
Switzerland what you have particularly
in a place like Norway right is a really
really high level of cultural
homogeneity you know a high level of
capital that exists that doesn't exist
in the United States and quite the same
way so it's Mike's fault
that's one make sure that's what it's
the fault of the blacks know that it is
the fault of cultures that are not its
culture that's right I forgot what the
alright that's the Norwegians ask the
Norwegians have significantly curtailed
immigration from the Islamic world
specifically because they're having
problems of cultural assimilation I
probably have a really good conversation
because they have a higher higher
literacy rate they have more public
education there and of course their
populace is generally healthier because
they have socialized health care and
they spend less on health care their
population is healthier and has been
healthier for decades because they don't
need as much crap as Americans to
virtually all wealth generation that
happened in the Nordic countries
preceded the socialist redistribution
systems that people like Bernie Sanders
Elizabeth Warren of kasnia Cortes loved
Norway was actually ranked higher in
terms of relative health to the United
States in the 1960s and 70s than it is
now and that's because again these are
countries with very high levels of
social capital a tremendous work ethic
sure a certain level of egalitarianism
between men and women that goes back
generations that was not established by
radical feminism and what you've seen is
actually a lot of difficulty in a
similar similar immigrants in Nordic
countries there's a great book called
debunking utopia by nima Sun and Angie
that's that's totally worth reading on
this he's an actual Iranian immigrant to
Norway and he talked specifically about
the shortcomings of immigration in these
places it turns out that it's much
easier to become employed as an
immigrant in the United States than it
is in in Nordic countries yeah well they
also do have better
bitter healthcare outcomes overall was a
lower percentage of their GDP being
spent per average person so I was also
pretty important let me ask you well
care system is a disaster area but
that's that's largely to do with
governmental regulation no not the
blacks it's about it's not about any
particular race obviously it's about a
mishmash of regulation and deregulation
that has created some of the worst of
all possible worlds although the United
States still leads the world when it
comes to five-year cancer survival rates
for example so if you can afford health
care in the United States it's still the
best health care in the world
Benjamin Shapiro really color are you a
Nazi okay we're gonna move on so I've
read that you have made the claim that
capitalism is like consensual sex
socialism is rape and the one thing I
think that's interesting right now that
we're talking about is sort of where the
line is first if I disagree if it's
democratic socialism when we're talking
about the public consenting by a vote
and I know you're gonna say not everyone
goes along with it but that's true of
any law passed right democratically we
have all kinds of look that you'll never
get a hundred percent of people to agree
on a law but in this case we're talking
about socialism versus capitalism do we
really think that's that's a fair
comparison that it's like non-consensual
sex versus rape and where do you draw
the line I mean it seems to me like you
enjoy some some social programs some
socialism is okay you use public roads
if I'm not mistaken roads are the public
roads and public goods generally our
non-rival wrists and non-excludable
that's what makes them public good so
it's not quite the same thing right now
you're talking about
everybody's access to a road that
everyone can use and I can't exclude you
from use of that Road in the same way
that the military is non-rival wrists
and and non-excludable
that's the definition of a public good
that's not the same thing as alienation
of my labor so the question really is
your rights you know when it comes to
sex you have the right to consent or not
to consent when it comes to how I use my
labor I have the right to consent or not
to consent and you voting to remove my
right to consent or not consents does
not alienate the right it just means
that you're violating it that's
interesting that you know you bring that
up ray talking about the right to work
but what about what about
the right for example of people who are
working to be in healthy conditions to
be in at least a humane conditions are
these laws that you support you know
workers rights know what I'm getting
into unionization or collective
bargaining I like what they're
bargaining better than in fact if again
if you want to use these favorite
socialist countries as examples you know
places like Denmark and Norway ik have
have much more use of collective
bargaining by by unions for work
conditions than they have regulation
from the top down because that allows
the workers to actually negotiate with
the employers on what work conditions
should look like I don't have a problem
with private unions getting together
collectivizing and then you know
negotiating with with management but I'm
not a big fan of the idea of a top-down
cramdown that happens from a government
entity that rarely knows how a business
runs and again prevents people from
actually using their labor as they see
fit just not when it's public roads
police or military got it I just want to
make sure that I'm clear on it's not
excludable goods well let's talk about
that none rival it's not excludable
College then that's a great example you
know you have rising to it if you have a
30 if you have a classroom of 30 people
let's say eight years ago and it's
twenty thousand a semester today that
could be as high as thirty five thousand
a semester if you look at the rates the
inflation you look at how much college
loans cost still 30 people in that
classroom you're not talking about
adding more people at that point so we
could apply a lot of these rules as far
as non-rival it's non-excludable know
not college the use of a college because
the use of professors does prevent other
people from using the professor's
professors do not have an unlimited
number of people that they can teach
they have time commitments they for
grading papers they have to they have
that there are only so many hours in the
day
that is by nature rival risk and it is
also excludable in the sense that if you
don't pay for the college you don't have
a right to use the college that's not
the same thing as a road where anyone
can use the road and there's not a
police officer they are it's not like a
toll road police officers not there to
prevent you from actually using the road
the same thing is certainly not true of
a college campus if you walk into a
college campus today without paying
tuition sat down and started taking
classes then you would quickly be
removed no I can tell it doesn't happen
I do it do it all I sit in on classes
all the time and I do not get removed
and you know I'm very grateful for
professors who are open-minded enough to
allow people are going to learn because
I think they're the heroes of our
country teachers of all ages of all
stripes and they don't get appreciated
enough when we're talking about like
we've said thirty people in a classroom
what if what about limited amount of
pupil let's say colleges can we just set
a certain amount of colleges and say
okay this is the sign-up sheet after
this we're Philip so it becomes an
unrivaled or not excludable and not all
colleges but could we do that and make
that I'm not sure well now you're
actually limiting the supply so what
you'd actually want to do is have a
free-market system where supply meets
demand where there are a number of
people who want to go to college and now
you have people competing for that
dollar without federal subsidies to
major in stupid things and then you can
get a loan I mean uh I had no problem
getting a law school loan my wife had no
problem getting a medical school loan
because these are actual careers that
you can pay back the money you are gonna
have a little bit more of a problem if
you're a Gender Studies major and you
want to get a loan for a Gender Studies
major from a bank there's no collateral
and the chances of you getting a job
outside of a Gender Studies professorial
are pretty low you're practicing law
today I've been havin for a while
actually there's a you know I think
steven crowder used to practice law for
him for a little while but he turned out
to be just an awful client so I say it
turns out that was a really useful
degree right while we're throwing jabs
out there I think that you're not being
honest when you make it seem as though
the only people who can't afford college
are people who are taking these you know
these more sort of niche degrees there
are plenty of people out there who own
Applied Sciences we can't afford school
we don't know right that's the thing if
we're going to talk about placing a
priority as a society because we all
have values I would seem to me that it'd
be better spent on education health care
than the military-industrial complex
that's ok different strokes so what
about public schools right there
definitely rival was excludable don't
fit the definition of public goods would
Benjamin Shapiro Daily Caller is
completely abolish public education
I have some severe questions about
whether we should actually be be
utilizing public education as opposed to
local private schools in parochial
schools so I think the public school
system has turned out to be in large
measure a disaster I also do think that
there is a difference between a small
community deciding that they want to put
together a local school and the federal
government
ramming down on people across the nation
what exactly federal standards should be
because again the levels of agreement
inside a small cohesive community are a
lot higher than they are across a
country of 330 million people with
diverse viewpoints and cultures and and
decisions to make about education okay
so I think you didn't really answer my
question what would you do with public
schools yeah your choice you get rittany
we don't have a federal department
education is up demolish the federal
that yes we should have polished the
federal Department of Education yes what
was that exactly
because colleges yeah okay what's
fascinating in the United States is
after you look actually look at the best
schools in the United States they are
all at the upper level where supply and
demand dictates the quality of the
education America's college system is a
very very good college system by any
global measure America's high school and
junior high and elementary school
systems are by and large not and the
only good elementary and junior high and
middle school and and high schools are
the ones that exist in communities that
spend not only more resources but have
parents who are are usually dedicated to
high levels of education in their
children regardless of income right so
this is right we avoid we say cultural
right we don't want to actually say like
Jewish families and Asian families and
not the blacks right that's what's going
on okay I got you it sounds so you think
all schools should be private basically
K through 12 college that's it is that
your solution I think that would be a
good start and I think that if you are
going to have a public school system
then it should be as minimal as possible
and it should be designed at the local
level and again I think local
communities deciding what they want is a
lot better than then massive communities
deciding what they want I sort of abide
by Montesquieu's rules on this the
devolution of authority to the lowest
possible level is the best way of
achieving any sort of consensus well you
know that brings me it's interesting
enough that brings me to my next point
you just talked about smaller
communities are the people who should be
building schools from the ground up okay
so we privatize all schools right how
many public school no no longer K
through 12 or college so you know you
can you can
but you can listen you can have public
schools but the public schools have to
be done at the local level where the
level of consensus is a lot higher than
across the country okay
so we're talking about communities where
they have consensus and you just said
that they perform higher in certain
communities right communities with
families right maybe dad you stay in the
house but we don't want to get into the
racial stuff what about kids whose
parents can't afford just send them to
school we're talking about those private
schools or they're in a community where
they don't have a community have the
resources for it so they're deprived of
an education because their parents
poverty and that brings us back to isn't
that again what we see a system that
perpetually keeps the rich rich and the
poor poor especially education well
number one this is one of the beautiful
things about religious education in
particular is that the amounts of
charity that exist in private school
systems for for people who are going to
religious schools extraordinarily high
it is also true that when it comes to
people who don't have opportunities
available for their kids we need folks
making responsible decisions about how
to raise their children and whether to
bear those children in the first place
whether to get pregnant in the first
place but if a parent isn't able to take
care of their kids usually the if you're
not willing to do what you need to do to
educate your kid then you know we ought
to talk about whether you should be in
control of that child in the first place
yeah a bench bench Bureau dealer called
advocate for eugenics apparently now
that's where we've gone so what we're
talking with this is the school and
we're talking about we're talking about
the economy and capitalism versus
socialism great school education sounds
to me like you're okay with a system
that like we just talked about sort of
keeps the poor poor and the rich rich
here's the thing which I want the 1% is
the number that's earner I know people
don't like to talk about the 1% but big
corporations right they make their money
what we're talking about systemic
oppression and I think education
factored into that this is capitalism
versus socialism I've heard your
argument morally speaking they make
their money off of exploiting those at
the bottom of the economy
to me that's nonsensically outrageous
and immoral if we're comparing to
economic systems one that says all right
we have to place priority have to we
have to determine what we value as a
society education healthcare or one that
says it's a determine what we value as a
society
the ability for the wealthiest people in
the world to get wealthier at the
expense of others
sounds like that's what you're
advocating privatize schools I'd like to
know I'd like to know how the wealthiest
people in the world get wealthy at the
expense of poor people who have no money
in the first place particularly when you
see that statistically literally half
the world's population has been raised
out of poverty since 1980 specifically
because of free markets capitalism and
private property rights yeah well this
is a problem of the right that salt
right in the right wing today it's sort
of it's this autistic view of the world
and that you know if you have an iPhone
fine you don't have to worry about any
more right technologies that's not what
really matters I'm talk about people you
know get out in the street right talk
with these people see how people are
living in the United States I don't
think you understand the point it's not
about how much money the poor have I'm
not saying that the rich are mugging
them in an alleyway they're not getting
rich off of the poor's money they're
getting rich off of exploiting their
labor right this is because the rich
owned the means that since the
Industrial Revolution they own the means
of productions where do we don't want
that to go to the government but we want
it to be in the hands of a few people
who get billion-dollar bonuses while the
while the poor can't even get a living
wage of $15 an hour sure they make $7
people on planet earth the poorest
people on planet earth live in one of
two systems either a system that does
not guarantee private property ownership
because there is no actual governmental
system to guarantee private property
ownership or to a system where private
property ownership does not exist and
the government owns the means of
production and does not operate in even
state capitalistic fashion but operates
for the quote unquote good of the
workers when that happens poor people
emerge this is what's happened in
Venezuela that's what happened in the
USSR is what happens in Cuba is what
happened in North Korea or alternatively
it's what happened in places like
Somalia or Sudan again the idea that
rich people are somehow exploiting labor
unless you can show how they're doing so
by pointing a gun at somebody or using
another government gun to point at
somebody
free alienation of Labor is a is a
fundamental human right your decision to
work for a given wage is your decision
and no one's forcing you into it it's
this simplistic reductive you know on
the spectrum view of how the world works
we're not just talking about how much
money people have in there
we're talking about a system right now
that doesn't frankly allow poor people
to become the next Pope brother or the
Walton family you know the what Walmart
is probably one of the biggest one of
the biggest recipients of welfare in the
country because they don't even pay
their people living wage C I mean what
we're talking about capitalism it's
totally cool to bail out banks it's
totally cool to make sure that oil
companies get subsidies but once we
cross the line into education
that's where we draw the line now you're
on your own that's that's that yeah
that's not capitalism subsidies to
Walmart is not capitalism that state
sponsored that state sponsored
mercantilism essentially it's it's
really closer to economic fascism and
the Minaya greed that Walmart would be
actually forced by the labor market to
pay its workers more if you did not have
the government picking up the the food
stamps on the other end that is a
supplementation of wages by the federal
government toward businesses like
Walmart I don't believe that big
businesses should be receiving subsidies
from the federal government any more
than I believe that individuals
generally should be receiving subsidies
from government so oh okay so if well my
welfare just didn't exist if EBT cards
just didn't exist Walmart would pay $15
an hour is that a fact mr. Mehta
economist well they would in fact have
to raise their wages because people
cannot work for a non living wage or
they would be dead by definition do you
think Walmart cares if you die in a
gutter they don't care they can't get
you to work I mean if they've they got
no one to stock the shelves cuz you're
dead in the gutter I do think Walmart
Kerris yeah I don't think I don't think
they care I think they automate and this
is a problem we see now with it was new
technology listen there aren't the same
kind of jobs for people not everyone's
gonna be a Harvard lawyer not everyone's
gonna be a Harvard lawyers wife /dr
right some people actually have to go
out there and work on the assembly line
and make the nice things that you enjoy
but that becomes automated and these
people get left behind right that's we
have 7 million unfilled jobs in the
United States right now 7 million
unfilled jobs in the United States right
now and essentially record low
unemployment so I'm failing to see the
millions of people who are desperately
missing a job other than folks who
probably should move out of communities
where
factories died 25 years ago oh yeah so
that's their solution just I move it's
not my problem really well no it's the
fact is that America was built by people
who are moving America was built by
folks who crossed an ocean and left
behind property ownership and family to
build a new life and then it was built
by people who cross the Appalachians to
go and stake out claims in the middle of
nowhere and try to build a farm at risk
of death so yes I think that you driving
20 miles down the turnpike to get a job
fracking as opposed to being in a town
where there are no jobs it's probably a
worthwhile endeavor so there we go to
fracking and well you don't think that's
a moral imperative to make sure that we
deliver a world that our children can
inherit you just saw the reasoning is
significantly less damaging to the
environment than any other form of
drilling and natural gas is
significantly better for the environment
than a variety of other forms of
carbon-based fuel
yeah what about solar what about wind
what about doing what German has done
the only options aren't natural gas or
oil yeah
solar will no nuclear well nuclear power
powers all France and we could do that
but people on the Left don't like
nuclear power because they are scared of
things that really have not happened
yeah cuz Chernobyl is just a figment of
my maniacal than the idea that Walmart
would start doubling its pay if the
government which is powered itself for
decades on nuclear power is is a worse
example of nuclear power than a poorly
constructed Russian atomic facility
mm-hmm yeah which also doesn't make a
whole lot of sense as to why your guys
in bed with them right with him Russians
Oh trumped in bed with Russia yeah oh
that's tax Chernobyl on it I don't know
I don't know what huh yeah well that too
listen he's a babbled a lot of people
and he's having them he's having the
ladies you know piss on the fur mica and
videotaping it my point is listen I mean
right now we're taught you guys were the
party of Red Dawn right I thought we
were talking about capitals but all of a
sudden your buddy buddy with the
Chernobyl guys Rush honey explain that
one well a couple things one I'm not
sure when the left decided that they
were anti-russian that's been funny
since Barack Obama pledged flexibility
in 2012 did nothing when they invaded
Ukraine and cry
I did nothing when there's gravity Syria
yeah so there's that and then as far as
the actual policy listen presidents from
President President Trump's rhetoric on
Russia is not good I mean I'm not a
defender of President Trump on his
rhetoric with regard to Vladimir Putin
I've thought that it's awful
throughout but his activity with regard
to Russia has been significantly harder
on Russia than anything the Obama
administration remotely approached so
you seem to discuss economics a lot we
just talked about resources so let's
take let's not talk about nuclear right
away right or nuclear is your previous
iteration called it that's always a good
sign when someone can go to go to Yale
and come out and not pronounce the most
basic of words maybe you knew some
people who spent time with at Harvard I
don't know so let's take that off of the
table here even if we're talking about
natural gas if we're talking about coal
any of these it still is a finite
resource right capitalism does not have
any there's no moral imperative to move
to something that's renewable if
something that is a more toxic
alternative let's not say horrible for
the Americas let's go with what you say
right say ok fracking is better than
then then the typical kind of extraction
methods fro all right listen let's get
let's give you that it's still a finite
resource there's no profit motive to
move to something more healthful for the
environment until it runs out well I
mean there has been a profit motive to
to move to more helpful technologies for
the environment considering the
significantly higher gas mileage that we
get now than we used to in the 1970s and
what was the what was the profit motive
there presumably government
subsidization vehicles that use less
Phil they use less fuel
now as government subsidy it's the same
thing that people the Conservatives they
all tried to complain about Tesla
government subsidies the government
stepped in and offered incentives for
more fuel-efficient cars it was not it
was not mere subsidies alone it was it
was also the fact that there was high
demand as oil prices rose for smaller
vehicles when oil prices go down there's
less demand for for smaller vehicles
when oil prices go up there's more
demand for smaller vehicles also the
left has been complaining about the idea
of peak oil for some decades now and
we've not yet reached peak oil plus with
regard to technological development what
I love to see whoever cracks the code on
renewable cheap energy is going to make
more money than anyone
history of humankind the big problem
here is that Solar is simply not capable
of generating the amounts of energy
necessary to power entire civilizations
and carbon-based fuel is the most
efficient source of energy although I
can hold on a second ring-ring Angela
Merkel oh it's for you she says that's
[ __ ] all right
I burn a bra they've got is they've been
using solar and wind for years they they
move their entire energy dependents to
renewable resources
well Germany is taking an enormous
amount of actual gasoline and natural
gas from Iran so that's that's not
completely true they've converted all of
their energy all their national energy
to solar or wind Germany I mean there's
not a good time I took government
intervention right I know it's not the
military I know it's not I know it's not
the police force right we're on board of
that but I'll be honest with you mr.
Durden I don't know that much about the
the German energy situation so I will
have to check that out and get back to
you no shocker no shocker Benjamin
Shapiro avoids learning about Germany
and their current affairs let me ask you
Benjamin here before we go to you I know
you're a busy man in today's day and age
the person who screams the loudest and
his most hyperbolic I get it it was more
popular so I know you have a platform
you've a lot to do any how what closing
thoughts would you have for the audience
I want to make sure they understand you
would privatize all schools K through 12
colleges not offer a welfare EBT to the
poorest among us not want us to convert
to renewable energy and you're ok with
some 1% getting richer while the poor
stagnate I want to make sure they have
excellence now by the way I would
mention you know justjust from a quick
Google search er but the share of
renewable electricity in in Germany
represents as of 2017 about 35 percent
of their total consumption so the idea
they've converted entirely to solar wind
is just not true well I don't know what
you're bringing up it's probably write
your own Daily Caller link so after this
we can we can you know go back and check
check it out but I know that they
actually had it as a national order to
make sure they move entirely to
renewable check your source
but is there anything that you I want to
make sure that I understand if I've
gotten anything incorrect for the
audience because they'll make up their
own mind everything as much as humanly
possible we should devil if we should
devolve my authority to the local level
we should ensure that people have the
freedom to use their use their labor as
they see fit and keep their property as
they see fit and we should also have a
thriving social capital we should also
have a thriving non governmental belief
in one another that's the other part of
this that is required it's not just pure
libertarianism and free markets you
actually do have to have a virtuous
people that is crafted by a civilization
steeped in the idea of right and wrong
pure capitalism alone is better than
pure communism and pure socialism alone
a virtuous people is necessary however
for freedom to truly coexist with a
thriving and virtuous society that's the
other part that we never talk about but
I think that it's sort of important to
note would you like to talk about time
you want to grab a couple minutes to
talk about that I want to make sure
Hollis I know you were you know I'm not
going by I'm not going by a cue cards
here I'm going by right the old noggin
but I wanna make sure all and let me
look this up yeah hold on
virtuous in all right speak is a synonym
for white but let me allow no yeah good
so it's you said you want to discuss
this it's necessary what do you mean by
virtuous maybe that makes all of us make
sense just let's waive the virtuous wand
right well again you mentioned at the
very beginning of this interview
actually the idea that the Bible
mandates that people give charity I
agree with the basic idea that a as John
Adams put it our Constitution is fit
only for a moral and religious people
meaning that you need people are
committed to the idea of helping one
another outside of government or people
are going to do is you've done and call
for an increase of government to fill
every life gap there are certain areas
of socialism that are destined to fall
down almost immediately there are other
areas of socialism that are destined to
fall down over time but it remains an
attractive solution to folks who refuse
to acknowledge that there is social
network and that there's a social safety
net in a social network existing outside
of government alone if you believe the
government is the only guarantor of
fairness you are going to end up in the
socialist camp if you believe that
is the is the chief guarantor of a
hand-up and in that forming thriving
social bonds is the is the necessary
adjunct to a free society then you're
gonna be more in favor of individual
freedom yeah I uh I don't know that I
agree with that but I appreciate that
you know you bolstered your claim by
quoting old dead white guys I notice
that's a real constant and I think
that's gonna be doing your party wonders
in the midterms and future elections so
it seems like okay as long as everyone's
a moral person and find this whole this
whole capitalism thing will all work out
just provide your time everybody else
that everybody has to be and that
everybody has to be a moral person but
you do have to have enough moral people
in a society to help fill in the gaps
where capitalism does not solve problems
for everybody widows orphans people who
can't take care of themselves okay so
capitalism would work at people tomorrow
it just hasn't been done right it just
hasn't been done correctly yeah assuming
that assuming that people are amoral
assuming people are amoral capitalism
works better than any other system in
the history of planet Earth assuming
that people are moral capitalism still
works better than any system in the
history of planet Earth if you actually
want the best of all available systems
what you need is capitalism combined
with a moral and virtuous people it's
just my neck is sore from the rigidity
you're so rigid capitalism or all social
if no one's talking about Vanessa you go
to Venezuela you don't go back to
Denmark and Sweden in Norway right we're
talking about a blended economy as many
of the successful economies out are out
there that no they're not called the
United States of America
between socialism and capitalism and we
already have that here in the United
States the conversation really comes
down to what degree you draw the line at
roads and military and the police force
industrial complex I say let's toss
education health care into the mix but
let's let the rest of people decide
Benjamin Shapiro it's the Benjamin
Shapiro program if I'm not mistaken did
I miss anything are you good bro that's
where it is man go for it all right and
I'm sure you've got a lot to do I'm sure
you've got some people to harass they're
in a college campus and they're a viral
video out of it scarlet urn I hope it's
been illuminating for everyone out there
and I think next time I don't know who
have on next time exactly but I think
we'll be discussing feminism in rape
culture but right now I need to take a
hot bath